ومن عمان معنا الان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز
وانت تتابع المشهد الان والطريقه التي
يتكثف بها القصف الروسي وايضا
القصف الاوكرانيه على مناطق تسيطر عليها
روسيا كيف تقيم مسار المعركه الان
يعني الان
هناك حديث عام وهناك حديث محدد في الاطار
العام موجات القصف اصبحت متباعده نسبيا
قياسا مهما كان يجري سابقا قلت الكثافه في
هذا اليوم ارتفع اعداد الصواريخ لكن
الذي الملفت للنظر ان النجاعه في التصدي
تقريبا بحدود 50 الى 55% فيما في المرات
السابقه كانت تصل الى 80% خاصه ضد
الطائرات اذا موجات القصف هي مرتبطه
بابعاد سياسيه وبابعاد عسكريه استفزازيه
من قبل الجانب الاوكراني لكن الاهداف في
معظم الحالات هي منشات الطاقه الان الحديث
عن المعارك تبقى
هي حجر الزاويه في مجمل العمليات العسكريه
التقييمات متباينه السيطره على 40% شرق
نهر
باخبودكا
والسيطره على بعض البلدات قطع ثلاثه طرق
الابقاء على طريق واحد تباين المواقف
السياسيه ما بين
الاناقه بالقاده العسكريين من اجل اتخاذ
القرار العسكري المناسب للتكيف مع المعركه
وما بين القرارات السياسي الذي يعلو والذي
اصر على ضروره الدفاع وبالتالي في معركه
باخمت التوصيف نحن امام معركه تاخذ اكثر
من بعد ميداني منها اجتياح جبهوي منها
عمليات تطويق والسيطره على الطرق ولكن
المرحله الحاسمه في معركه باخمت قد يفاجئ
البعض لم تبدا بعد لماذا لان العمليه
الحاسمه تتطلب عمليه عبور للنهر تتطلب
السيطره على 60% هناك محاوله امداد وتعزيز
اذن
ستدخل سيدخل طرفي الصراع في معركه
نسمع مره اخرى
الاستهداف الممنه ضد المنشات الطاقه في
اوكرانيا وسدادنا تحتيه بل ان الهجمات
اصبحت الان تتصاعد ضد اهداف في كييف
العاصمه الذي يمكن ان نستنتجه من هذا
النهج الان الذي تدار به المعركه من قبل
روسيا
يعني اولا دعنا نفصل بين كيف وما بين محطه
جبر وجيه محطه زبروجيا هذه تقريبا للمره
السادسه او السابعه تتعرض القصف ولكننا
نقف امام مفارقه مفارقه عجيبه الجانب
الروسي يتهم الجانب الاوكراني والجانب
الاوكراني يتهم الجانب الروسي
ولم لم يتم حسم هذا الخلاف وهذا الجدل حتى
من قبل وكاله الطاقه الدوليه هناك ست
مفاعلات المفاعلات هي لا يمكن مقارنتها
بتشير نوبل تشيرنوبل مكشوفه هذه تحت الارض
محميه هناك ضمن مكعبات وحواجز اسمنتيه سته
مفاعلات تنتج 6000 كيلو واط في العام
الواحد
معززه بمبردات ديزل 18 مبرد لديها مخزونات
لمده 10 ايام حتى وانقطع التيار الكهربائي
لكن التخوف يكون من اليوراني يوجد في هذه
المنطقه 30 طن بلوتونيوم واربعين طن من
اليورانيوم المنظم بدرجه
فاصل صفر سبعه واحد واحد اي بمعنى اخر اقل
من الاشعاع النووي لليورانيوم الطبيعي
انما كميه التقديس هي المشكله ليست درجه
الاشعاع بقدر مع ما تحدث عن سبعين طن اذا
لا تزال الان اعتقد انها وان انقطع التيار
امامهم عشره ايام لاعاده التزويد بالديزل
للمولدات او لاعاده الربط الكهربائي فيما
يتعلق بكيف اشكرك عذرا للمقاطعه دكتور
فايز الدوري الخبير العسكريجي من عمان
شكرا لك